c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ça alors
pour moi ce serait j'ai failli dire il
tortue n'ont plus rien au hasard à une
tortue d'un tuba ça c'est ce que c'est
j'ai été en voir récemment mais il y en
a plus que des petites à la ménagerie du
jardin des plantes
c'est les petites tortues c'est dans le
bon sens ça c'est une tortue mâle parce
qu'en voile bitonio sur le côté et ça
rentre dans la semaine
ces tortues qu'est ce que ça peut être
un gros poisson
arrêtez de me dire vous savez même pas
ce que vous montrez un radeau radeau de
la méduse
il ya un truc pour un crochet d'un
voisin finaux un ornithorynque c'est ça
bah oui ok ok je me suis trompé d'animal
un cochon gonflable
c'est un truc qui fait une boîte à
bonbons mais vous êtes comment veux tu
que je devine et moi il ya des appareils
à une bouée poucho elles mais elles
échappent votre wii la wii la bouée
cochon elle est dégueulasse c'est un
ordi tabac voilà il a la tête de
l'ornithorynque alors ok vous avez fait
une cote tortue sur une tête dans des
torts un coq et c'est un hybride
[Musique]